welcome back to our very uh special
episode
um you know what it's not even a show
we're just here in a time machine and
we're back 25 years ago because it's the
25th anniversary of Ever After and
I literally can't even believe that I
get to be here with my sisters my
stepsisters
Melanie lynskey and Megan dogs
I mean okay
you guys is it true that you and I
didn't know this you guys lived together
during this production yeah okay tell me
everything yes are you gonna keep the
wings on well Chris I mean they are
amazing it's like I've got to try to
make it work but you know this is
bringing me back too okay oh I think I
can do this okay hello very elegant very
nice
laughs
I'm so jealous why wasn't I living with
you guys we had a great house we had a
great house yeah we I think you had the
upstairs and I had the downstairs yeah I
mean it was massive yeah and it had a
gorgeous view of the dordoing river
valley and it was just fantastic we had
our own little car that we tooled around
in oh my God but I think we crashed at
one point where's the cupboard do you
remember we crashed the cat and we were
trying to like get somebody to help us
and you went up to a man and you were
saying in French was every problem
instead of
instead of I think it would be news news
Avon probably but we're in such a panic
so essentially Megan was running up to
this man and yelling you have a problem
he was like what wait did you guys like
do photography in a field too what is
that story because that's my new
favorite oh my God so I I don't know
what I was thinking at the time it was
just kind of like oh this would be
really groovy to do let's go take
topless photos in the corn field
I cannot love it more
oh my God yeah
oh my God
by the way this is like no days three of
knowing each other yeah right and the
suggestion was made and I was like okay
sure
you know what a nice breaker Lucy uh
Lucy Liu took um
nude photographs of me on Charlie's
Angels too oh I guess it's just what us
girls do
I want to be a girl and I just wish that
our Prince Henry could be here because
it just isn't the same without him you
know he is a true Prince Charming I mean
he really really is
[Applause]
thank you
I'm so happy to see you we are all so
happy to see you you look well by the
way oh thank you very you all look
amazing do you remember like getting the
part me us meeting do you remember that
yeah I do remember
the part in London and I I sort of been
rejected the first round of auditions
but my agent sort of managed to get me
in the room again I begged I begged them
I said give me another chance give me
another chance I think that's how I got
the part but uh down to you as well I
think you went to bat for me so thank
you very much
I mean there was nobody else it was
supposed to be if I was lucky enough to
be a part of this reimagining of a fairy
tale that I never thought twice about
what we were telling little girls to
wait for the prince to rescue them which
worked fine for
centuries
adventurers until you came along and
rescued me
I mean yes you did Brother magnificently
as I seem to remember yes I did have to
lift you up at one point
um and we were very particular about
that and we had to put you on harness
because we wanted it to look so real and
unfortunately as strong as a person as I
was inside you are a big all-man guy and
I couldn't scare you so we have to make
it like look seamless and perfect and of
course we were in the woods so we were
like where are we gonna hang the wires
from and but it turned out really
perfect
let's go
I love it
[Music]